finally new rule here on inauguration
day in the interest of new beginnings
liberals have to stop calling Trump
voters rubes and simpletons and instead
reach out and feel their pain the pain
they insist we didn't see and there is
ample evidence for that pain did you
know that of the 14 states with the
highest number of painkiller
prescriptions per person they all went
for Trump Trump won 80% of the states
that have the biggest heroin problem and
the counties that he won in Ohio and
Pennsylvania that went for Obama last
time are the ones that are racked by
opiate abuse so let's stop calling Trump
voters idiots and fools and call them
what they are [ __ ] drug addict
[Applause]
now if that sounds like I've actually
not reaching out I promise I will but
first I have to get something off my
chest about this phenomenon of white
conservatives on drugs and the numbers
are phenomenal West Virginia was Trump's
best state and in the past six years
folks there have down 780 million hydro
and oxycodone pills that's four hundred
and thirty three pain pills for every
person in the state West Virginia's
mascot is a dilated pupil in Wisconsin
another key Trump state between oh wait
in 2014 heroin deaths nearly quadrupled
I never thought I'd hear myself say this
but kids don't do heroin it's a gateway
to being a Republican and the thing that
sticks in my craw about this is that for
decades it was us liberals who were
accused of destroying the fabric of
society with our drug use remember the
country anthem from the hippie era that
put the counterculture in its place
Merle Haggard okie from the Skokie we
don't smoke marijuana in Muskogee
we don't take guard trips on LSD yet
today miss Cokie population 38,000 has
nine drug treatment centers they should
change the lyrics that we don't share
our needles in the Skokie we don't mix
our smack with PCP
somewhere along the line things changed
for the real Americans in the heartland
who are always chastising us for
undermining patriotism by being stoned
all the time who stoned all the time now
not us we've moved on to kale smoothies
and an occasional craft beer meanwhile
you've got meth mouth and are taking
your dog's arthritis live free or die
more like brush down and sweat but I'm
not saying Trump voters that your pain
isn't real I mean it isn't but I'm not
saying because if this election has
taught us anything it's that anything is
real if enough people believe it is and
the good news is if the problem is drugs
well hell there's something I can help
with if it's one thing I know it's how
to manage a hi I'm doing it right now
you shrunk borders or stone please we
liberals invented stone this is common
ground we get high and bid a thousand
bucks for a Beatles lunchbox on eBay you
got high in order to president from
Moscow but that's because you're new to
drugs so so let me share a lifetime of
wisdom and experience in getting [ __ ]
up things like don't mix pills and
alcohol but if you do oxycodone goes
with white wine it's nice working close
refresh don't drive on pills call uber
or lyft and have someone on pills Drive
you it's very important always have a
wingman someone just say cool it or you
shouldn't drive or don't put that in
your mouth
Woody Harrelson once pulled me away from
a long conversation with a Christmas
tree I swore was Elton John also very
important you're doing the wrong drugs
stick to the stuff that comes out of the
ground 90 percent of you are farmers you
grow fertilize harvest eat and for all I
know [ __ ] your own crops you never talk
to smoking and most important ignore the
[ __ ] across the bar who keeps staring
at you that's a mirror